vous êtes sur rtl
owni.fr
rtl matin à vie qui tombe où
il est 7 heures 42 excellente journée à
vous tous qui nous écoutent alba ventura
vous recevez donc ce matin le président
du mouvement l'est républicain christian
jacob bonjour christian jacob bonjour
alors est-ce que vous aussi comme eric
ciotti vous voteriez eric zemmour en cas
de duel avec emmanuel macron c'est ce
qu'il a dit au grand jury rtl hier pour
écouter ça ça n'est vraiment pas là la
question du moment on sort d'un week-end
formidable avec les jeunes nous avons
rassemblé plus de 1600 1700 jeunes hier
des républicains nous sommes maintenant
la première force politique de france en
nombre de militants et surtout un grand
mouvement de jeunesse qui est née hier
plus de dix mille jeunes adhérents aux
républicains la présentation du projet
d'alternance
mais ça vous gêne ce qu'eric ciotti en
face existe et non en france quelle
candidature d'eric zemmour ça vous gêne
eric a des convictions il en fait part
il a des choix à 810 a bien sûr pas non
mais bien entendu mais simplement c'est
vraiment une question qui ne se pose pas
parler d'un candidat dont on ne sait pas
s'il sera candidat et puis qu'à 8% on
peut bâtir toutes les hypothèses sur les
gens qui sont à 5 % 1 6% à 7 pour ça
n'est pas le sujet du moment
c'est pas le sujet du moment mais il
n'empêche tout le monde en parle et dans
votre parti tout le monde en parle
certains disent il va prendre sans doute
à marine le pen mais il va prendre aux
candidats de droite aussi avec 1 8% moi
j'ai plutôt le sentiment qui est sujet
de préoccupation des français voyait
c'était le pouvoir d'achat c'était la
sécurité c'était la santé s'était pas
tel ou tel candidat médiatique mais je
comprends qu'un cartel ça prenne une
teneur particulière par des noms mais il
est infréquentable règle absolument pas
absolument pas mais ça n'est pas le
sujet écoute et moi on veut bien se
passer la matinale a parlé de zemmour
m'enfin honnêtement on vient depuis deux
ans de remporter victoire sur victoire
les républicains ont tout gagné depuis
deux ans et vous m'accorderez qu'à
chaque fois on nous a pas vraiment
annoncé la victoire avant expliquer
qu'on était toujours dans des
difficultés croissantes et hop
on gagne les municipales avec une
victoire sans précédent les
départementales les régionales je
rappelle que les régionales la dernière
fois en 2015 le front national était en
tête dans six régions de france ils se
sont totalement effondrés il était en
tête que dans une seule région cette
fois ci on a un vrai projet qui était
présenté hier devant les jeunes qui a
été débattu avec les jeunes donc voilà
je sais la politique la politique c'est
j'entends jean sens bien ça la politique
il ya chez vous des adhérents qui
trouvent que le parti parfois un peu
trop centristes et qui se disent que
c'est peut-être moins tabou de voter
zemmour que marine le pen il ya des gens
chez vous qui dit ça il ya surtout des
gens qui ont travaillé que c'est un
risque que vous mesurez ça christian
jacob non je vois la ruche qu'il me
préoccupe absolument pas aujourd'hui on
n'est pas dans ce jeu là on est sur les
sujets de fond si aujourd'hui
après avoir un nombre de militants qui
s'est effondré pendant cinq ans depuis
deux ans on en train de remonter on
avait plus de jeunes en recréer un
mouvement jeune on travaille sur le fond
avec un vrai projet qui répond aux
attentes des français c'est ça la
politique c'est ça la noblesse de la
politique c'est très amusant d'entendre
lr dire le projet d'abord habituellement
c'est et les socialistes winnezeele il
enfin vous alliez d'abord un candidat
oui vous m'accorderez que depuis que je
suis à président du mouvement c'est ce
que j'ai toujours dit et c'est ce que
nous avons fait mais le ridicule de
parler moins et risquent en fait on est
dans un contexte où on sait pas s'ils
auraient une primaire ou pas ben vous
mais ce n'est pas ça aujourd'hui encore
une fois comme il ya deux ans je me
présente à la présidence du mouvement
j'ai expliqué les choses clairement en
disant qu'il fallait après
des échecs successifs nous avons perdu
deux présidentielles et deux
législatives
des européennes avec un résultat
catastrophique
dans ces conditions il n'est pas
interdit de faire preuve d'un peu
d'humilité et de pas dire qu'on a
réponse à tout mais de revenir sur le
terrain de bâtir un projet constructif
ensuite de renouer avec la victoire et
nous l'avons fait un salut les terriens
et parce que ce sera toujours la même
chose clr que le projet ce sera celui du
candidat
toujours été comme ça mais non mais non
vous avez tort vous avez tort parce que
voyez quand on commence à débattre du
fond mais on voit que les différences
s'estompent
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois que l'on
met les gens autour de la table on voit
bien que sur des sujets comme le pouvoir
d'achat comme l'immigration comme la
fiscalité comme la santé comme la
sécurité ou d'autres sujets et bien à
chaque fois on arrive à se rassembler et
bien évidemment qu'on arrive à venir le
temps de l'incarnation
on va pas se cacher là dessus alors les
primaires c'est oui ou c'est non
christian jacob mais ça on vous le dira
le moment venu et ce sont les militants
qui vous le diront lorsque cette suite
ils monteraient au créneau demain lors
de votre truc exécutif du sondeur eu
besoin de primaire val de primaires
mettent un processus de destruction
fratricide est dit il mais jamais il
s'exprimera comme les chacun s'exprimera
les seuls qui décideront ce sont les
militants parce que moi je tiens ma
légitimité et militant notre famille
politique et j'ai toujours dit que c'est
à eux que la décision reviendrait elle
ne sera pas pris sur un coin de table
elle sera pris de manière transparente
et claire à l'occasion d'un congrès qui
se tiendra le 25 septembre je ne peux
pas vous faire une réponse plus claire
que celle là vous rêver encore de voir
françois baroin devenir votre corps je
souhaitais je considérais que françois
baroin était indiscutablement pour moi
le meilleur candidat mais à une
condition c'est qu'il le soit qu'ils
aient envie de l'être je pense qu'il
n'est pas dans cette danse est élu c'est
lui mais c'est son choix je leur est
arrivé lundi vie d'avant je voudrais
reprendre une question de soulever par
eric ciotti hier au grand jury
d'ailleurs sur l'interdiction de la
kippa et du voile jusqu'à 18 ans est une
bonne idée
j'ai proposé il ya deux ans déjà au
président de la république qui ne m'a
jamais répondu
d'organiser une commission type stasi
sûr c'est sur ces sujets moi je suis
choquée comme beaucoup effectivement
quand vous voyez des petites filles de
10 ans 12 ans voilées de la tête aux
pieds
ça me fait réagir mais il faut que l'on
pose celui effectivement des mineurs sur
les signes religieux celui des signes
religieux dans l'espace public
et ça ça doit se prendre comme jacques
chirac l'avait fait avec la commission
stasi sur l'interdiction du voile je
pense qu'on est capable de se poser il
ya deux ans qu'on le réclame au
président de la république comme à
chaque fois incapable de de réponse et
ce quelque chose sur ces légers oui dans
la poésie elle l'est d'ailleurs nous
l'avons dit ce matin rejoindre rtl nous
avons relaté cette information à nice la
mère d'un dealer a été expulsé de son
logement c'est à dire que la mairie a
autorisé le bailleur social à l'expulser
ça aussi ça va dans le bon sens pour
vous on doit prendre des décisions comme
sa radicale pour que le calme revienne
en mai je pense que lol je sais pas si
l'argument était le seul quelle qu'elle
soit la mère d'un dealer ou s'il y avait
des dettes de loyer au dow jones tout
cela est encadrée par la loi ce qui est
certain c'est que on le voit bien avec
les déplacements à répétition monsieur
macron c'est inversement proportionnelle
à l'explosion de la violence la réalité
c'est qu'on est dans les coups de com il
fait des déplacements il fait des discos
rien ne change et les choses s'empirent
on peut pas dire que françois hollande
dans le domaine de la sécurité de la
violence était une référence mais la
réalité c'est que les choses se sont
empirées et empirer gravement depuis
quatre ans vous ne croyez pas ce grand
plan pour marseille sur
écoute comme vous aussi vous avez envoyé
votre parti a envoyé des ministres de
l'intérieur des croyants et bien sûr
l'avait bien sûr il ya aussi des
décisions de prises aucune décision
n'est prise qu'est-ce qui est effet
quand monsieur macron n'a absolument
mener aucune réforme sur le plan de la
sécurité mais c'est sur le plan
économique dans les trois ans qui ont
précédé la crise sanitaire aujourd'hui
on nous dit c'est la crise on peut pas
très bien mais avant qu est ce qui a été
fait est là on est à huit mois de la
présidentielle va nous faire des
déplacements 10 ans entend dès
maintenant vous allez voir tout va
changer alors c'est vrai sur la sécurité
mais c'est vrai sur le reste du nouveau
l'angleterre murray sur la sécurité il
ya une loi contre la changer quoi elle a
changé quoi
comme sur la réforme des retraites ce
qui était incapable de faire en quatre
ans et demi en six mois on va demander
une réforme de la retraite se fiche des
gens il ya une autre proposition d'eric
ciotti
des fonctionnaires aux 39 heures payées
38 salut je suis absolument pas d'accord
avec toi je suis pas d'accord avec cette
proposition
on dit non non non non vous devriez lire
notre projet je vous assure qu'il a
intérêt
à filer par le commandant pas de l'avoir
lu nous avons dit que le le temps de
travail doit augmenter simplement moi
j'ai à la fois pour l'harmonisation
entre le temps de travail dans le public
et dans le privé quand on compare les
choses aujourd'hui et à peu près 8 %
d'écart en moyenne où on travaille
davantage dans le privé que dans le
public en revanche chaque heure
travaillée doit être payé va pas
demander aux gens de travailler sans
être payé ça ça n'existe pas c'est la
raison pour laquelle sur les heures
supplémentaires nous demandons à ce que
le temps de travail soient définies au
sein de l'entreprise ou dans les
branches lorsque les entreprises sont
trop petit c'est à dire on décide par
référendum au sein de l'entreprise ou
dans les branches du seuil de
déclenchement des heures supplémentaires
est ce qu'on la déclenche à la trente
septième heure 1 38e la 39e ce système a
deux avantages c'est qu'il permet
d'augmenter le salaire parce que si au
lieu de travailler 35 heures vous
travaillez 37 ou 38 vous avez plus de
salaire et en même temps il n'amoindrira
la compétitivité des entreprises puisque
ils payent en heure normale n'est pas en
heures supplémentaires mais ça ça se
fait au plus près possible du bon de
commande dans l'entreprise faisons durée
y en a qu'on y travaille pas assez en
france on doit travailler davantage pour
permettre de gagner davantage c'est pour
ça que dans cette proposition elle
répond à la fois la préoccupation du
pouvoir d'achat à la fois celle la
compétitivité des entreprises et dans
votre projet il y à porter
progressivement l'âge de départ de la
retraite à 65 ans et mettre fin aux
régimes spéciaux merci beau pot
christian jacq commercial où les
républicains ont tout gagné depuis deux
ans municipales départementales
régionales vient de dire christian jacob
eric zemmour n'est pas le sujet du
moment merci à tous les deux
l'intégralité de l'entretien comme
chaque jour est à retrouver